Newt Gingrich has admitted the
devastating reason that Trump will win
it's not devastating to Trump it's
devastating to the Republican Party
Laura Ingraham Fox News propagandist
interviewed Newt Gingrich about the
entrance of Republican Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis into the 2024 presidential
primary and Newt Gingrich points out uh
DeSantis is plenty smart but he's not
able to talk to people who might only
have a third fourth or fifth grade
education the way that Trump is now the
start of this clip is a clip of DeSantis
talking about the financial system and
the framing is hey great that DeSantis
is talking about that but does the
average voter even understand this it's
a funny premise and then Newt lays down
the humiliating reality about the
average Trump or republican voter at
this point in time
we will not be a free Society if major
financial institutions can do through
the economy uh what people could not
achieve Through The Ballot Box our
rights will be restricted uh will be the
end result and that's not healthy for a
free country
now nude and it's a good point but is it
can people grab onto that and kind of
understand a lot the contract with
America what that what is he getting at
there I mean will you and I know but can
the folks around the dinner table
understand that who are not into
politics
this may seem like an odd comment but I
think that he's very very smart uh he
clearly did very well at Yale uh he is
uh clearly capable of thinking about Big
Ideas but you know Ronald Reagan was
probably equally smart but he also
understood that he had to communicate so
that every day folks understood it one
of Trump's great advantages is he talks
at a level where third fourth and fifth
grade educations can say oh yeah I get
that I understand it and in fact Trump
has now made the Republican Party The
Party of working Americans in a way that
probably hasn't been true for almost 100
years that's a bit of an exaggeration
but the point here is still an
interesting one uh so the challenge for
the Santa says take that interesting
sentence and figure out how do you boil
it down to a slogan and to a specific
thing I think it's fair to say and I
know this from the polling data we do at
the America's new majority project the
one American people fear big business
okay so the truth is that what Newt
Gingrich is saying is maybe an
inadvertent but completely devastating
burn of trump supporters and it exposes
the sad reality of the Republican party
today you can frame what Newt said there
in two ways and they're very different
you can say the Republican party is now
the party of the working class and
DeSantis simply needs to hone his Yale
education to be more uh understandable
and also align more with that working
class that is now the bulk of the
Republican party or something or you can
interpret that as the average Republican
voter is so uninformed and so often
ignorant that you need to dumb things
down so that even an adult with a third
grade education could understand it one
of those two interpretations has a much
more negative connotation and it's the
second one I believe that the truth is
clear and this is not about Republicans
are dumb
this is about understanding realities
the Republican party has become a party
how can I say this that appeals to the
lowest common denominator panders to
ignorance and fear and rejects facts and
science they also dis often dismiss any
nuanced thought
as left-wing nonsense and the party at
the same time doesn't want to invest in
public education and hasn't done so in
many red States they don't want to
promote critical thinking among its base
especially in red states where we know
that the educational outcomes are worse
than in blue States so as a result the
party the Republican party has alienated
many of these moderate independent
educated voters who are increasingly
voting for Democrats rather than
Republicans those are folks who value
reason and competence over rhetoric and
Charisma and DeSantis doesn't have
Charisma either by the way the data are
not blurry or unclear or gray it's
crystal clear as far as education and
red versus blue States you look at the
top 10 states with the best school
systems they were all blue States or our
swing states that voted Biden in 2020.
the reliably blue or swing but Biden
2020 you look at the 10 states with the
worst school systems and worst education
they were all red states that voted
Trump in 2020. so this is a reality
and whether you put a positive spin on
it like Gingrich does about the party of
the working people is now the Republican
party or you say this is an electorate
that has been dramatically dumbed down
by virtue of the policies they support
either way you have to recognize that
Democrats do have an edge over
Republicans when it comes to educational
attainment among American adults when
you look at
um bachelor's degree or higher
41 percent of Democrats have a
bachelor's degree or higher only 31
percent of Republicans do that's a
massive difference if you look at high
school only high school diploma or less
about a third of Republicans have not
gone beyond high school diploma and some
have even a lesser education than that
compared to only 28 percent of Democrats
whose educational attainment is that low
and this is a gap that continues to
widen and it's widening among white
voters as well education influences
political preferences and behavior
DeSantis is trying to position himself
as a viable alternative to Trump in 2024
and he talks about his record handling
covet and he talks about we were worst
hit but we did really well and he's
endorsing the culture War agenda of what
woke goes to die in Florida and he's
restricting voting rights he's
restricting what teachers are allowed to
teach he's planning critical race Theory
and trans athletes and allowing
permitless gun carry like he's doing all
of that stuff but Newt Gingrich is
getting to a devastating reality which
is that DeSantis at least so far and I
get it it's only been a few days but
he's been sort of campaigning much
longer than he's been an official
candidate DeSantis has not articulated
a clear and compelling message that
distinguishes him from Trump in a way
that will resonate with the broader
Republican electorate and Gingrich
accurately points out
DeSantis has to find some way to make
the case for himself it could be too
late and I know it's like he hasn't even
running been running for a week how is
it too late DeSantis may have already
alienated many voters with what happened
between the time that Trump announced
and the time that DeSantis announced and
now you've got Tim Scott and Nikki Haley
and all these folks taking just little
percentages of the electorate DeSantis
needs a path to more than 50 it's either
by taking everyone else's support
including some of Trump's or growing the
base by so much that he brings in people
who were who were not as of today likely
Republican primary voters if he can find
people who today are saying I probably
won't vote in the primary and get them
to say oh now I'm interested in voting
in the primary that's another path
forward I don't really see his ability
to do it and he's already talking about
pardoning Trump which I don't know
that's going to help him very much